welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid a lot of people say they don't
like numbers but they're kind of
unavoidable I mean we run into them all
the time keeping track of account
balances and speed limits and travel
times and tip percentages the list goes
on and on when you think about it
numbers really aren't all that bad when
they're just numbers anyway in science
the familiar numbers are called scalars
to distinguish them from other types of
quantities most other types are only
used by scientists and engineers but the
vector is much more common no no not the
character the quantity vectors are used
very often by programmers and pilots and
police even Park Rangers whether they
know it or not formally we say a vector
is a quantity with magnitude and
direction what the heck does that mean
yeah I know it sounds horribly
complicated let's break it down okay so
being extra careful here a quantity is
something you measure with a number a
magnitude is a size so in this case it's
just the size of the number that was
measured the direction is what
distinguishes a vector from other
quantities there are a ton of things we
measure they have direction in our
pursuit of dark blue sedan traveling
eastbound on i-94 between exits 197 and
198 radar reading 120 miles per hour
license plate alpha five Charlie echo
three Niner immediate backup is
requested there were two vectors in that
call we got a velocity from 120 miles
per hour and the word eastbound velocity
measures motion and the direction
matters if you want to make any kind of
prediction and where that speed is going
to end up also zero velocity means zero
motions so it's a very easy quantity to
understand we were also given a position
but the way it was given didn't really
make it clear on i-94 between X is 197
198 Detroit represent position is weird
though because the zero is kind of up to
you if you can understand how position
works as a vector then you can
understand how all vectors work so we're
going to use it as the example for the
rest of this video in order to work with
vectors we need a coordinate system the
term coordinate system sounds kind of
fancy but it's just a collection of
numbers assigned to places we do this
all the time with room numbers building
floors addresses and
fortunately those systems aren't
patterned enough to do the math that we
need to do if we're labeling position on
the earth the most widely used system is
longitude and latitude the zero is
located here and you count from there
either north south east or west the
location given in the police call is a
little over 42 degrees north and a
little over 83 degrees west so cool yeah
no right I'm going to be a huge bore
though and use the standard Cartesian
coordinate system it labels one
direction the horizontal with X values
and the other direction the vertical
with Y values and along each of those
directions you can be either positive or
negative
BAM solution it's extremely mathematical
I know but that's what makes it so handy
so do you know any good science or math
puns please share in the comments I'll
take jokes too and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
you